Traditions supporters of Julian Assange
demand his freedom during a rally in
Sydney
the WikiLeaks founder and Australian
citizen has been held in prison for
diplomatic refuge in the UK for more
than a decade
but his supporters hope they can bring
that to an end it's not just
Julian
who has lost his freedom but all of us
because in order to keep Julian in
prison they have had to corrupt
their own rules and their own principles
the sound just fighting extradition to
the United States to face charges of
Espionage Washington is pursuing the
journalist for his role in releasing
hundreds of thousands of classified
military documents related to the wars
in Iraq and Afghanistan Washington says
he's a national security threat who put
lives at risk
but supporters say exposed truths the
world's most powerful governments wanted
to hide it's about Julian
freedom
and the fact that he exposed a crime
that I was horrified about and he's the
one in trouble he's the one imprisoned
what we do want is the protest was
organized to coincide with a visit to
Sydney by the U.S president
but Joe Biden postponed due to talks in
his country's so-called debt ceiling
that didn't stop Los Angeles supporters
for me you know look at every human
rights NGO every press Freedom NGO in
the United States over 25 of the largest
ones and the international Human Rights
Watch ACLU all calling on the Biden
Administration to drop this because of
what it means to press freedom in the
United States Australian prime minister
Anthony Albanese has escalated
diplomatic pressure on Washington
calling for the charges to be dropped
assange's ongoing detention continues to
highlight debates between press freedom
and security concerns
and the supporters say they will never
give up campaigning for his release
David Landy Al Jazeera
as